we're asked what time is it so first we
want to look at the hour hand which is
the shorter hand and see where it is
pointing so this right over here would
have been 12 o'clock one o'clock two
o'clock three o'clock
four o'clock and it looks like it's a
little bit past four o'clock so we are
in the fourth hour so the hour is four
and then we have to think about the
minutes the minutes are the longer hand
and every one of these lines represent
five minutes we start here this is zero
minutes past the hour then five minutes
past the hour then 10 minutes past the
hour so the time is the minutes are 10
10 minutes past the hour and the hour is
four or it's 4 10.
let's do a few more
what time is it
so first we want to look at the hour
hand that's the shorter hand right over
here it's at let's see this is 12 1 2 3
five six seven eight
nine and it's between nine and ten it's
just past nine so it's still in the
ninth hour it hasn't gotten to the tenth
hour yet the ninth hour is from starting
with nine all the way until it's
right almost before it gets to 10 then
it gets to the 10th hour so the hour is
and then we want the minutes
well we can just count from 0 starting
at the top of the clock so 0 5 10 15 20
25 30.
it's 9
30. and that also might make sense to
you because we know there are 60 minutes
in an hour and this is exactly halfway
around the clock and so half of 60 is
30. let's do one more
what time is it
so let's count this is 12
1 actually we can even count backwards
we can go 12 11
10.
so right now we're in the 10th hour the
hour hand has passed 10 but it hasn't
gotten to 11 yet so we're in the 10th
hour and how many minutes past the hour
are we so this would be 0 5 10 15
20 minutes past the hour that's where
the longer hand is pointing it is 10 20.